you know you really captured his Essence
playing the photograph I'm Adam Chloe
I'm sure you're not gonna make fun of me
all right
oh my God this might be the nicest thing
anyone's ever done for me landscape with
invisible hand is a story of a young
artist coming of age and falling in and
out of love in a world that has been
taken over by aliens
kidding me hey park somewhere else
these aliens take over our economic
system which puts a lot of people out of
work this new alien Empire is very
fascinated by Humanity itself so the
main export from Earth is love they
don't have love in their culture they
find romantic stuff super exotic and
interesting Chloe has the idea to
broadcast their relationship to the
aliens basically doing live streams of
them like going on cute little dates
that's what I loved about this really
over-the-top science fiction metaphor
the only thing that humans can still
sell is what makes them human
and 300 total they put on these little
nodes that project everything that they
can see smell hear touch it has become
obvious you are deceiving your viewers
what deceiving
I will take you to court and your
families will be in debt for
approximately six Generations
[Music]
[Applause]
all of us had this feeling that there
was just something off about the world
there was something alien about the
world uh we're part of this system that
just feels so far away so impenetrable
so confusing I hope that people are
fight a reflection of this moment that
we're living through right now you
didn't invent courtship broadcast
audiences can expect some laughs do you
want me to cut that for you
some tears
you've lost a lot since you guys came in
here they can expect to be talking about
it for a while they can't expect to be
like oh you know what this reminds me of
today
foreign